between the demonic possessions the
psychic possessions the star-crossed
politics the brainwashing the drug abuse
relapses and all the drama between the
teams members Titans can get a little
complex dick Grayson's evolution from
Robin - Nightwing has been simmering
ever since the very first episode of
Titans while he's still dressing as
Robin in the beginning of Titans first
season the root phrase that shocked fans
as soon as the first series trailer
dropped was a signal that the Boy Wonder
needed to get out from under the Dark
Knight's shadow
he eventually burns his Robin costume an
act that earns him no end of ire from
Bruce Wayne suit may curse - in season
two's penultimate episode and assures
Jason Todd that he's no challenge to
Jason's role as Robin eventually he's
forced to ask himself exactly what Todd
asks him if he isn't Robin who is he new
costume the same dogged by his own inner
Bruce Wayne dick eventually comes to
terms with the need to evolve beyond
Robin as well as beyond being merely
Dick Grayson when dick gets himself
thrown in prison he finds more
inspiration from a fellow prisoner who
carves an image of his home village
guardian Alice Sewell or bluing and
Spanish onto their prison cell wall once
he finally realizes Jericho is alive
within his father's body dick breaks
himself out of prison eventually he
makes his way to Stu who along with Lily
had already been busy making dick his
new outfit in Nightwing the titular hero
finally arrives and gives Deathstroke
the fight he deserves
while we see Slade Wilson accidentally
kill his son in the flashback episode
Jericho there have been hints for a
while that Jericho was alive body
hopping
[Music]
here's how she could do with that in
season two's 11th episode it's finally
confirmed that before he died
Jericho psychically jumped into
Deathstroke's body and had been waiting
for the chance to escape as he's
reviewing his memories of his last
face-to-face with Slade dick notices
something that escaped him earlier while
Slade himself offered no forgiveness his
hands made the ASL sign for I forgive
you but dick can't save Jerico on his
own for Jericho to escape his father's
body he needs another one to inhabit
that's where his sister Rose aka Ravager
comes in at the end of Titan season
two's eleventh episode we learned that
Rose originally agreed to stay with the
Titans on Slade's orders as his mole but
in large part because of her love for
Jason Todd Rose tells Slade to go to
hell since Jason has left her by
Nightwing her loyalties seem if he is
first but thankfully Rose turns on her
father and encourages Jericho to jump
into her body to save himself moments
before Rose kill Slade Jericho
if you're in there you know what to do
it remains to be seen exactly how
Jericho and Rose are going to handle
being two minds in the same body but
considering Rose lets her brother out to
talk to Nightwing right after Slade's
death we already know Rose will be
better about sharing that her father was
on the face of it mercy graves goals
don't seem very complex
she's got dollar signs on her mind
Nightwing opens with mercy remotely
introducing Connor to a group of world
leaders willing to pay top dollar for
their own super soldier after showing
the bidders Connors SuperSpeed and
immunity to bullets mercy tells the
group to tune in later that night the
show mercy as planned includes
triggering the brainwashed gar into
going on a rampage in a crowded carnival
than sending Connor in to stop gar help
is arrived
once the Titans show up mercy keeps the
camera rolling in hopes that seeing
Connor beat upon bonafide superheroes
will drive up the bidding even further
eventually things don't go as Mersey
hoped and we learn her unforgiving
employer Lex Luthor is calling to find
out what the problem is
while mercy wants top dollar for Connors
super
Howard services it's likely money is not
lex luthor's ultimate goal here in
conner the episode that shows us Connor
and Kryptos escape from Cadmus we learn
Lex and his people went to great lengths
to successfully create Superboy to do
all that just for money isn't lexis
style at least not as he appears in most
media in most likelihood the money is
just a fringe benefit to the main goal
getting Lex's own super soldiers in
place in an influential government
psychic visions and illusions are
definitely a recurring thing on titans
they can be used against the heroes but
they clearly can also serve as a benefit
sometimes even proving to be the thing
that saves a hero's life it's trigons
psychic infiltrations that bring most of
the titans under his sway in the season
1 finale and season 2 premiere while the
visions Rachel gives dick are exactly
what frees him from her father's control
the same proves true for Connor in
Nightwing and this time it's both dick
and Rachel who enter Superboy's thoughts
and free him from Cadmus as conditioning
why is it dick instead of Rachel who
appears to Connor a couple of reasons
seem likely first Rachel is able to free
dick by entering his thoughts in part
because she and dick have grown close
but no one in the Titans really knows
Connor very well at this point gar
probably knows him best and by the time
Rachel hits Connor with her powers gar
still down for the count
second Dick's recent experiences in
prison and his evolution to Nightwing
help him relate to a teenage boy who's
barely had the chance to figure out who
or what he is tell me how I can help him
third and finally it's just cool as the
thematic sons of Superman at Batman
Superboy and Nightwing needed to share
some screen time in the season finale
initially once dick in Rachel's efforts
free Connor from his conditioning
everything seems cool dub here's a young
girl complaining that her doll was left
on a ride so she grabs the doll and
brings it to the girl as she does a
metal tower damaged during the melee
with Superboy Falls toward dove and a
group of civilians Donna Troy charges
forward and holds the tower aloft but
the energy from the tower electrocutes
her she's able to keep the tower up long
enough for dove and the innocents to
escape and finally she drops the tower
and collapses dead on top of it it seems
strange that something like this could
kill Donna Troy even accepting that
power levels of the characters in the
show can differ quite a bit from their
counterparts in the comics moments
before Donna proves herself to be the
only Titan capable of holding her own in
a fist fight with Superboy anyone who
could survive a few punches from a
brainwashed connor should be able to
survive an electric shock fairly easily
but maybe her fight with Superboy is the
answer to how the shock kills her she
does prove herself able to withstand
hits from Conor but not for long it
could be that her confrontation with
Superboy weakened her to the point that
something that would normally only stun
her could prove fatal we see the
assembled Titans hand Donna's casket and
her golden lasso over to what appears to
be an honor guard of women on an
airstrip these are famous spirits
of women warriors who hail from the same
mysterious island as Donna Troy and
Wonder Woman it's no surprise the famous
Koreans would ask the bring Donna's body
back to their Island though it is
interesting how their leader whose name
we don't learn looks at dick seeming to
regard him with a great deal of respect
it's likely Donna told her fellow famous
Kieran's about the Dark Knight's Protege
and it's only natural they would respect
someone they saw as an accomplished
warrior as well as a loyal ally of one
of their own in Nightwing we see
Rachel's powers evolve in ways we
haven't seen before after Corey is shot
by Deathstroke Rachel's able to heal the
wound
later when gar is still in tiger farm
and recovering from the beating he took
from Connor her powers again are able to
heal rather than hurt letting her snap
gar out of his brainwashing and without
the kind of psychic infiltration she
uses on Connor and even though these are
the first times we've seen Rachel's
powers manifest as healing rather than
hurting it shouldn't be that much of a
surprise that she can do it this is why
Rachel leaves for the mascara with
Donna's corpse she hopes she might be
able to develop her powers enough to
bring Donna back to life I should go
with Donna if anybody can help her it's
me the island may be the perfect place
for Rachel the famous currents are more
used to the existence of the kind of
magic that courses through Rachel and
are probably better equipped to survive
when her powers go a little nuts as they
so often tend to do the decision Hank
and Donna pier to make at the end of
Nightwing to stay broken up but to still
work together in the Titans may seem
strange in light of everything it's sure
to bring plenty of tension and conflict
in season 3 particularly if Don and Dick
Grayson's old romance reignites in the
wake of the break-up but beyond planting
seeds for future drama there are some
good reasons why the pair would make
that choice first of all they've done it
before in both of this seasons flashback
episodes Aqualad and Jericho Don and
dick are a couple though Hank still
remains on the team with them both by
the end of the second season the Titans
have become a family once more and it's
a family that both Hawk and Dove helped
create whether they're going to continue
their romance or not they both have good
seasons to stay together on the team
regardless of the potential for jealousy
or conflict it may not be the healthiest
choice in the world but considering the
kinds of decisions both have made in the
past it certainly won't be their worst
Bruce Wayne shows up throughout Titan
season two but mostly as a phantom he
appears regularly to dick as part of his
psyche both to pay tribute to Bruce
Wayne's of old and harshly forced some
much-needed revelations upon Grayson
toward the end of Nightwing we're
surprised to learn that we got even more
of phantom Bruce than we knew in season
two's eleventh episode Rachel Corey
Donna and Dawn all received different
messages summoning them to a diner in
Nevada where Bruce Wayne appears and
encourages them to do what they can to
keep the Titans together when Corey
mentions this meeting to Wayne IN
Nightwing he politely tells her she must
be mistaken because he doesn't remember
the meeting she's talking about Corey
offers a possible explanation to dawn as
to how this could be that the Bruce
Wayne they met was an illusion
unconsciously created by Rachel along
with all the messages that summoned the
Titans to the diner there's some proof
to support this we've certainly seen
Rachel lose control of her powers before
at one point even bringing a killer
Stone gargoyle to life without her
knowledge
so could Corey be right absolutely
but until Titan season 3 at the earliest
there's no way to know for sure
Titans first season ended with a
post-credits scene introducing Connor
and Krypto this time around instead of a
post-credit scene we get one right
before the credits and rather than
introducing us to a new Titans Ally we
see the return of a villain we see only
briefly earlier in the season Blackfyre
the alien queen is Corey's sister who
led a violent coup on their homeworld of
tamarind and sees Corey is an
unacceptable loose end we see a woman in
a grocery store parking lot buckling her
daughter's into her car she's about to
unload her groceries when some kind of
purplish substance strikes her the woman
walks away from the car transforming
into the much younger looking black fire
we first see black fire as only a
hologram in atonement but now it looks
like she's found a way to physically
fest on earth ow well the substance that
hits the unsuspecting woman in the ear
is the same substance that strikes
Cory's friend and former lover fidei in
Atonement somehow the substance has the
ability to allow black fire to possess
the victim's body it could suggest there
are already black fire loyal tamarins on
earth otherwise where did the substance
come from did it just fly out of space
on its own it could be that black fire
will be the big bad of season 3 and that
rather than demons or mercenaries next
year the tightness will be facing an
invasion of Body Snatchers check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the belt so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]